There is a new war on Christmas for Republicans
that's playing very heavily on Fox News and
other right wing media.
And it is so called cancel culture.
Now, never mind the irony of people who supposedly
have been canceled and silenced regularly
appearing on national television like Fox
News to claim that they no longer have a voice.
I understand the irony of that and the absurdity
of that.
Let's put that aside for a second, OK?
We are now going to look at clips of the fourth
type of response we're seeing to the outrageous
and disgusting comments made by Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green.
So let me catch you up on the three types
of responses we've looked at so far.
Republican Steve Scalise went with attack
Joe Biden when asked about Marjorie Taylor
Green.
We saw that yesterday.
That's response type number one.
Republican Congresswoman Nancy Mace said there
are crazies on both sides when asked about
Marjorie Taylor Green.
That's the second response.
A what about ism type of thing?
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham, as we just
saw, said maybe the comments were taken out
of context, which in this case is a form of
gaslighting.
That's the third type of response we saw from
Republicans.
And now response type number four is Republican
Congressman Jim Jordan, a disgusting person,
by all accounts, going with.
If we were to punish Marjorie Taylor Greene,
it would be the cancel culture.
He actually says in this first clip from Fox
News yesterday, think of the cancer culture.
Let's watch and listen about cancer.
So there are many members of your own party
who are taking issue here.
Let's take a quick break and listen to Karl
Rove on this very issue.
We'll get your response, Congressman, if you
believe that the Jews control a space laser,
that that starts fires in northern California
and that there are some unnamed high ranking
government official who's got to hear to for
unknown security classification called Q and
all the nutty things that flow with it, you
should be taken off the prestigious House
Education Labor Committee and confined to
the dark recesses of the first building away
from the House floor and then let the voters
decide in the next election she is a problem
for our party.
Congressman, your response?
No one no one is condoning the remarks that
she made.
I've not heard any Republicans say that those
are appropriate.
So that's not the issue.
The issue is once this starts, tell me where
it ends, Sandra.
Where does it who's next?
Let me think of the council culture, Sandra.
I said this on January 13th on the House floor
during debate.
I told the Democrats, if you guys keep going
down this road, keep attacking people, their
First Amendment free speech rights, where
does it end?
It won't stop with Republicans.
It'll go it'll go to all of us.
And 13 days later, what happened in in California?
Dianne Feinstein's elementary schools name
was taken off.
So this this will never end.
And if we don't stop it now, everyone, every
single American is at risk.
And that's what concerns me.
So Jim Jordan, a Republican from the party
of so-called personal responsibility, is saying
there, if there are ever consequences to people's
speech, it's council culture and it's bad.
There cannot be consequences to speech.
Per this statement from Jim Jordan, Jim Jordan
appears to believe that free speech includes
total immunity from having your speech lead
to repercussions.
And then Jim Jordan actually.
The audacity to say in the middle of a global
pandemic that still killed four thousand people
yesterday, cases plummeting, hopefully deaths
will soon, but still killing four thousand
people a day.
Jim Jordan has the audacity, the testicular
fortitude to say that cancer culture is the
most dangerous thing happening in the United
States today.
But you know what?
We have a First Amendment.
What I don't want is people canceling everyone
else.
That is the most dangerous thing happening
in our country today, right now.
Joe Biden says during his inauguration speech
he wants to unify.
Well, it's tough to unify when you're impeaching
a president who's already left office.
It's tough to unify when you're trying to
cancel 75 million people who voted for that
guy.
That is what's tough to do.
So I hope we can get past this.
I hope we can get back to embracing the Bill
of Rights.
Now, most people, upon hearing that, will
realize that nothing he's saying makes any
sense.
But this idea that any consequence to speech
is an infringement on the First Amendment
is a really dangerous idea.
And unfortunately, there are lots of Americans
who watch Fox News and think you can learn
about the First Amendment by watching Fox
News.
And that's really scary because they end up
believing this stuff.
Imagine the most dangerous thing, not the
virus, not the people who rioted at the Capitol
on January 6th, not the dangers of allowing
more and more time to pass without passing
covid relief cancel culture by which he means
consequences for Marjorie Taylor Green's insane
comments.
That is the most dangerous thing facing the
country.
Replace the words, cancel culture with consequences
and reinterpret this consequences for disgusting
speech would be the most dangerous thing in
the country.
What accountability is a slippery slope, according
to Jim Jordan.
And in truth, if you know anything about Jim
Jordan's history, Jim Jordan's the last guy
who should be telling us what's dangerous.
He has a history of overlooking real danger
and has been accused of failing to report
abuse that was happening of college wrestlers
when he was assistant wrestling coach at Ohio
State.
I don't know if I'm supposed to call it wrestling,
but I call it wrestling.
He's the last guy to tell us about who should
be telling, who should be listing what is
most and least dangerous anyway.
He's horrible.
Jim Jordan is sort of the prototype of the
kooky American politician that the world sees
and wonders what the hell is wrong with the
United States.